[Applaudissements]
c'est en présence du Recteur de la
Réunion les élus du conseil général et
du maire du tampon que Nassima Dindar a
inauguré le collège du 12e au tampon un
collège flamban 9 qui accueille depuis
la rentrée dernière des élèves de 6e et
5e c'est un moment émouvement c'est un
moment de joie parce que dans la vie
d'élu rares sont les occasions malgré
tout d'être très heureux et et puis
c'est un moment de responsable parce que
je crois que nous portons à la Réunion
en matière d'éducation une un vrai enjeu
et et un combat mené depuis la
départementalisation et quand nous élus
nous coupons des rubans sur un
78e collège avec des regards joyeux des
équipes éducatives des enseignants
formés et puis le partenariat entre
l'État les collectivités une commune 20
millions d'investissement de la
collectivité pour permettre à terme à
900 élèves d'intégrer cette nouvelle
structure pour le maire du tampon il
s'agit d'un établissement des plus
modernes le du 2 km a aujourd'hui son
collège c'est un établissement qui est
considéré comme étant un établissement
des plus modernes et que donc là nous
ensemble qu'à la première rentrée mais
lorsque il fonctionnera à pleine vitesse
il sera à peu près à 900 étudiants 900
élèves et donc cela correspond bien à
nos besoins et puis après il faudra
envisager de préparer le prochain
terrain pour accueillir un autre collège
le collège du 12e qui s'inscrit
également dans l'intégration de l'autre
puisqu'une classe ulice sera accueillie
il s'agit d'enfants en situation de
handicap une salle aménagée spécialement
pour cet accueil et un collège doté d'un
ascenseur pour faciliter leur
déplacement il ne s'agit pas seulement
de cliss mais au-delà des classes ULIS
avec un vrai accompagnement et un
partenariat avec
laadapi oui je crois que nous avons
encore dans le domaine de l'accueil des
élèves en situation de handicap encore
beaucoup de travail à faire mais
rectorat éducation nationale et
nous-même nous y travaillons chaque jour
pour améliorer avec le partenaire de la
MDPH et les conditions d'accueil en
milieu ordinaire pour ses élèves une
structure totalement moderne des
aménagement de salle avec du matériel
informatique un CDI coloré et beaucoup
d'espace pour permettre aux élèves de
profiter de leur moment de détente le
collège du 12e est un exemple en terme
de qualité environnementale une
structure qui fait le bonheur des
enfants bah il est formidable on mange
bien les profs ils sont hyper chaleureux
euh bah voilà avec les nouvelles install
avec toutes les nouvelles installations
euh les nouveaux terrains le gymnase les
classe et voilà professeur la la cantine
est bien et bah c'est chouette parce
qu'il est neuf et il est pasé du ouais
il y a un ascenseur et il est génial il
est très beau il est neuf donc du coup
il y a pas les grands qui sont là pour
nous embêter il y a la nouvelle peinture
on était les premiers à rentrer il y a
une nouvelles choses au moins on a des
tables neuves des chaises neuves des
lives neuves et voilà quoi c'est neu
c'est joli et voil le collège du 12e
accueille actuellement 400 élèves une
autre origin
os au élèves de quitter le cours d'art
plasti pour se rendre par une porte qui
donne sur la terrasse histoire de
s'inspirer de la superbe vue pour
éveiller leur esprit
créatif